savez que je finis par l'amour et dans
le prê je m'en fous je m'en fous
mec personne ne tombera dessus euh j'ai
fini par l'amour et dans le prê hier
cétait le dernier épisode de la saison
18 et il y a eu des surprises hier soir
il diffuser un nouveau numéro donc et on
va débriefer l'émission avec un invité
un invité de marque un invité que
j'adore voilà ça j'adore voilà lui voilà
j'adore voilà ça j'aurais aimé produire
une émission comme l'amour et dans le
pré voilà je me retrouve à
voilà on débute avec ce déb ce débrief
avec Charles l'agriculteur qui avait
péchud Véronique alors qu'il avait perdu
une dent vous rappellez de ça oui bien
sûr il explique comment il avait prévu
de la réparer et bien j'espère qu'il
prévoit pas une reconversion dans la
chirurgieire pas son délire regardez tu
perdu ta dent ou quoi
ou j'avais cassé en mangeant du pain à
la dent oui oui et donc bah de ça
j'avais pas le temps de faire réparer
donc ah donc tu l'avais juste recollé
comme ça donc j'avais prévu un de la
colle forte pour recoller donc j'avais
recollé la DSE sur laappareil avec la
colle forte
pardon c'est toi qui avais mis ton truc
et de la colle mais genre de la colle la
col col normale mais c'est pas fait pour
ça c'est pour ça que ça tenait
[Rires]
pas B cette mascarade ça être vite fait
oui bon comment ça va Charles merci
d'être là merci on s'est vu en en loge
on sembrassé je peux te dire j'ai bien
senti ta moustache ça m'a
fait merci d'être là chéri merci alors
tu en es où toi relou ben moi j'en suis
que voilà l'amour dans le prix c'est une
très très belle émission mais bon j'ai
des choses à dire là-dessus tu pe dire
maintenant ou ah ouais ouais je non je
me présente parce que voilà et on on m'a
quand même on m'a quand même présenté
comme quelqu'un de quand même très très
hard ouais c'est vrai tu veux qu'on voit
regarde je vais voir regarde on va voir
ton casach comme tu es casaches ce que
vous aimez c'était des relations disons
charnelles et euh voilà tu es voilà tuas
tuas tu as voilà tuasas tu as fait des
tu as fait des vannes tout ça tu vas
nous dire pourquoi ils t'ont présenté
comme ça est-ce que ça te plaît ou pas
voilà regarde regarde mon je suis très
impatient de rencontrer mes prétendantes
j'ai déjà dit à Karine que fallait faire
l'amour tous les jours sinon on casse la
machine tu nous as appelé pour demander
leur date de naissanceou pourquoi faire
tu alors ça c'est un truc alors plus il
y a d'étoiles tu vois plus compatible
avec toi tu as Sexe amour sexe moi j'ai
un humour qui est plus je sais pas si tu
connais mais à la Big ah oui d'accord
tant tu as pas ité t reste dans le tu
vois bon ben on a fait le tour merci
hein je me laisse pas parce que je suis
un gros feignon ah non non il est hors
de question tu te mets debout tu dis au
revoir comme tout le monde quand
même
alors al oui bon alors pour en revenir à
tout ça alors moi je vais t'expliquer ce
que enfin on se tu toi ou on tu me tuois
ça bon alors l'amourpris c'est une très
très belle émission donc ça c'est
généralement quand on dit
non non ça se décortique en plusieurs
morceaux d'accord ouais bon tu as la
production Carine le marchand ouais tu
as les candidats ouais hein et donc la
production eux c'est ils ont une machine
qui est très très bien huilée ils savent
on n pas ils ont pas besoin de nos
conseils pourç là hein bon donc ouais
c'est très très bien hulé et tu as aussi
Karine l mararchand elle qui met sa voix
sur des sur des euh sur des bandes qu'on
lui qu'on lui propose hein donc moi j'ai
vu l'émission hein ouais ouais quand
Karine Le Marchand elle est venue chez
moi parce que c'est eux qui sont venus
me chercher B ou moi j'ai jamais rien
demandé moi non jamais et et je suis
c'est la 10e fois que je passe sur un
plateau mais je ne suis jamais passé en
direct j'ai une toute petite association
ouis d'accord he euh avec mes chevaux
donc j'ai déjà passé deux fois sur C8
avec les animaux de la h il ils m'ont
passé plein plein de fois hein ça
s'était super bien passé sauf que là
l'amour est en bon j'ai peut-être dit un
petit peu des choses que j'aurais
peut-être pas dû dire mais en en
attendant eux l'amour et dans le Pr ils
savent faire parler les images d'accord
donc ils prennent des morceaux ils
collent des HE tout tout ce qu'ils ont
envie de coller et puis en entre
parenthèses ben ça donne tout ça sauf
que moi l'émissions quand ils sont venus
me chercher j'ai dit à Karine j'ai dit à
la personne qui qui m'a demandé ouais
j'ai dit je veux bien faire cette
émission à condition que que que et que
et j'avais mis trop de de voilà j'
j'avais mis trop de comment de de
réserves et et donc ça plaisait pas tout
le monde hein et et donc quand quand moi
j'ai
participé donc j'avais exigé que Karine
l mararchand vienne chez moi dans ma
cabane parce que je suis un mec qui ne
vit pas comme les autres hein donc comme
je ne vis pas comme les autres forcément
ça intrigue hein et et donc après ils
sont venus on a réussi à se mettre
d'accord hein et puis et puis il en est
sorti ce qu'il en est sorti quoi tu es
pas tu es pas content alors de ce qu'il
en est pas du tout alors moi j'en ai
tiré plein de satisfaction personnelle
ouà
alors on m'a mis dans leagon du vieux du
vieux Gou du vieux pervers en voilà
alors quand au départ au départ quand
les quand les filles elles ont elles ont
écrit par exemple si on met ça dans les
mains de le courrier par exemple dans
mains dans les mains d'un fin liimier
comme comme Gill
ver de la ver de la ver
lui
lui et lui pourrait décortiquer ça parce
que tu vois quand ils sont venus au
bilan le bilan il était clair Karine
elle a bien proposé elle a bien présenté
le bilan sauf que après les filles donc
elles m'ont écrit les fillesin donc et
moi je moi j'avais fait cette émission
pour mettre pour mettre j'ai tout faux
hein tu voulais trouver l'amour toi non
non non j'avais mis l'émission j'avais
fait j'avais fait cette émission
justement pour mettre l'image de la
femme en au
ouis c'est ça c'est ça ah oui on va voir
regarde regarde regarde regarde regarde
regarde
regardee tu es la première arriver mais
c'est toi qui choisis la chambre que tu
veux puis si tu prends la mieux et en
fait je vais peut-être aller dormir avec
toi non non non non ah quand
même je peux vous prendre tous les deux
si tuux juste un coup
là pas dire des choses comme ça
Mar les fantases pour l'instant il sont
c'est très moyen hein comme truc notre
affaire bah ça veut dire quoi à un
moment donné il faudra que ça se
bouge j'ai peut-être été un petit peu
prétentieux quand même moi j'ai un zizi
il est il est
énorme Norte bah ouais non mais c'est
[Applaudissements]
hein jeis M6 ils te font dire des trucs
voilà non non mais attendez attendez je
suis d'accord avec toi hor hor c'est
horrible
attends
attends les filles quand elles sont
venues chez moi donc j'ai voulu les les
accueillir
non laiss parler déj c'estile j'ai voulu
les accueillir dans un git pour que que
ce soit décent bon bref en tous les cas
les filles quand elles sont venu chez
moi elles sont venu elles ont vu ma
cabane hein et tout le portrait il était
ce qu'il était hein donc Karine elle a
pas tricher sauf que les filles elles
m'ont écrit des lettres elles m'ont
envoyé des photos on est bien d'accord
et et donc quand elles ont écrit sur ces
lettres là moi je veux pas faire de
polémique parce que sinon après ils vont
dire
ouais bon bref vous voulez dire que
c'est pas bien monté quoi on dire que
c'est pas bien monté il est bien monté
il
ditant c'est
pas la question nétait même pas là la
question en fait c'est quoi ton problème
en
faiti t problème le vrai probl problme
c'est que non il est en train de vous
expliquer que ces dames là elles
savaient comment il était en à l'avance
avant d'écrire la lettre et que toi tu
es parose et si un un marin comme
voulait décortiquer ce courrier avec
l'accord des femmes là vous auriez une
vraie émission parce que les femmes les
femmes en question elles savaient très
bien où elles allaient elles allaient à
l'amour et dans le Pr elles allaient pas
au péérinage à l'Our hein hein quand tu
vas au pélerinage de lourd tu'emmène ton
chapelet hein quand tu vas à l'amour tè
chose
heinou
ou
alors que ce que je ne comprends pas je
comprends pas c'est que ces femmes elles
étaient outré outré parce que soitdisant
je voulais faire l'amour avec elle sauf
que
Oh l'amour est dans le Pr non mais
c'estou ça sauf que des SPE moi j'avais
dit j'avais dit que çait ça allait pas
faire parce que les femmes elles m'ont
envoyé des photos elles m'ont écrit des
choses dedans qu' fa qu'il faudrait
décortiquer mais bon si si je fais
ça je j'ai l'impression que tu étais
venu vraiment pour parler pas du
tout
tout du tout mais comme vous l'AT
souvent Ahou tu as bien fait e Alain en
fait
toi tu as fait chaud dans
la avec l'amour non mais ce qui vous
contrarie c'est la réaction des des deux
dames
non ça je suis non je sais ce que je
vous moi donc je ne suis pas du tout je
suis pas du tout contrarié moi si si
l'émission l'émission m'a pas satisfait
parce que justement ils m'ont classé
dans le vagon du yeux pervers hein on
est d'accord et sauf que après toutes
les belles images qui ont été tournées
sur quiibron sur la côte sauvage sur sur
la forêt de vosselland avec des comptes
et tout tu ne peux pas mettree parler de
ton zizi c'est non mais mais non non
mais pu voir des paysages
fabuleux voilà exactement je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi j'aurais
été producteur j'aurais accè sur kbron
pas sur ton Ziz voilà voilà voilà oui
mais non non mais ça c'est des mots qui
ont été collés ça he tuas tu as 200
heures de tournage tu as 200 heures de
tournage faut passer 25
minutes ou qu' mie non il prenent ce
qu'il y a de mieux sauf que si
aujourd'hui si aujourd'hui on te pose
une question est-ce que tu aimes la
soupe tu réponds oui ou non demain on
jeis pas s ça pass faut re acccord il
faut tout le temps habillé pareil et
tout pour qu'il puisse voler les
morceaux et et si demain on te dit
finalement tu es un vieux pervers tu
réponds oui le oui de la soupe hein et
ça n'a plus rien à
[Applaudissements]
voir en fait est-ce que tu aimes la
soupe oui là je prends le truc ou et là
est-ce que tu es un vieux pervers tu
prends le oui de la soupe voilà
voilà la télé c'est maouille et
compagnie j'ai tout compris c'était quoi
la question pour le Ziz énorme
alors
ou alors
non la soupe voil la
sou mais non mais non le ça j'ai jamais
j'ai jamais dit ça comme ça ah d'accord
c'était quoi alors le
contexte contexte est venu que que moi
j'ai dit j'avais un peu des blagues un
peu un peu comme à la Bard d'ailleurs
j'aurais bien aimé qu'il soit là
Jean-Marie je et donc j'avais des des
blague un peu comme ça et j'avais dit à
Karine en rigolant j'avais dit dis moi
tu sais on parlait de zizi donc avec
Carine vous êtes avec les
de ce qui s'est passé avant avec Karine
alors nous avec Karine toutes les tous
les il il y a eu le comment le portrait
après il y a eu le speed et après il y a
eu le
bilan voilà et après est-ce que tu
est-ce voulez bien rester avec nous de
petites secondes rester avec nous là oui
oui hein de
quoi j'ai pas compris t'inquiète à tout
de suite
t'inquiète